Prof: Okay.
Let us start,
ladies and gentlemen.
We're going to pursue the issue
of musical form today.
It's an important thing to talk
about because it allows us to
follow a particular piece of
music,
and we'll be--I am using this
metaphor of a musical journey
and wanting to know where we are
in music throughout the day
today.
Form is particularly important
in all types of music--
popular music as well as
classical music--
and we have this complex of
material coming at us,
this sonic material.
And we try to make sense of it,
and we say that it has a
particular form.
And we say it could have a
particular structure even,
so we tend to use metaphors
having to do with architecture
and things such as this.
What we are really doing here
is taking all of this sonic
information that's coming into
our brain and getting sorted,
and makes us want to dance
around or clap or be sad or
happy,
and make sense of it in terms
of a few rather simple patterns.
And musicians like to have
forms because oftentimes it
tells them what they ought to do
next and where--here--I'm here
but what ought to happen next?
Well, if you've got a tried and
true musical form that other
musicians have used over the
years,
you might be inclined to use it
too because your know your
listener will be able to follow
you.
Now the other day,
I asked early on in the course
about the form in popular music,
and I threw this out not really
knowing what the answer would
be.
What's the most common form
that one encounters when dealing
with pop songs?
And for the most part there was
silence across the room,
but one student--I have tracked
him down--
Frederick Evans,
gave a very good answer--
really a better answer than I
could have given.
So, clearly Frederick knew
something about this idea of
what he I think referred to as
"verse and chorus"
structure.
I might call it "strophe
and refrain,"
but it's the same thing whether
you have it in a Lied of Franz
Schubert or in a piece that I
know nothing about.
And Frederick is going to show
us--introduce us--to a piece
that I know nothing about.
I sent him an e-mail last night
saying, "Frederick,
you gave a really good answer.
Why don't you pick a piece,
come up and demonstrate
this?"
So this is Frederick Evans.
We're going--or excuse me.
Yeah, Frederick Evans.
He's going to come up here.
I'm told we have to give him a
microphone and he is going to
introduce us to this particular
piece.
Now you probably all know what
this piece is.
How many of you have heard the
piece we were just listening to?
Everybody knows it.
Who is the one person in the
room that's never heard this
piece before--has no clue what's
happening?
Moi. Okay?
So Frederick,
tell me about this piece,
please.
Frederick Evans:
All right.
This is a piece by 'N
Sync--back when I was in fifth
grade--
and it's "Bye Bye
Bye," and the pattern that
it follows is really the
archetype of a lot of popular
songs.
It's half of the chorus or so
when it starts and then there's
verse,
chorus, verse,
chorus and then what I call the
bridge,
which is like an emotional
climax.
And then the last one is a
really powerful chorus where
they just bring it home and then
the music fades away.
Prof: Okay.
So it's this idea of changing
text,
then coming back to familiar
text and familiar music,
then changing,
going back to the familiar new
text,
and then coming back to the
familiar in terms of the chorus.
Is that a fair shake?
Frederick Evans:
Yes, Sir.
Yes.
Prof: Okay.
So shall we play--what are we
going to hear first?
Frederick Evans:
So first you'll hear from
seconds twenty-four to forty.
This is an example of the verse
where they have the beginning of
the plot and then you have the
chorus at seconds--
about fifty-six--and that's
where you get your repeating
idea,
which is what the piece is
based on.
And then last but not least,
you have the emotional buildup
where the background and the
chord progression changes,
a little more solemnly,
and then there's the last
chorus that just brings it home.
Prof: Okay.
Great.
Let's listen to the-yeah.
>
Okay.
Frederick Evans:
Yep.
So that was the first verse and
that's when they really get you
into what they're talking about.
>
Prof: What really
interests me here is what
they're using is a baroque
ostinato "Lament
bass" but that's--
we'll get on to that in another
week or so.
So that's--okay.
Now we'll go to the bridge,
Frederick?
Frederick Evans:
Yes.
There at the bridge is where
they really sum up all their
emotions and they really just
want to tell you what they're
building towards.
>
Prof: Okay.
That's wonderful.
Thank you, Frederick.
That's exactly what I wanted.
>
Okay.
How many want Craig to continue
teaching this course and how
many want Frederick?
Let's hear it for Craig.
>
Let's hear it for Frederick.
I knew it.
Okay, but that's a good way of
getting introduced to the idea
of musical form.
Let's talk about form now in
classical music.
The forms are a little more
difficult in classical music
because the music is more
complex.
And before we launch into a
discussion of these musical
forms, I want to talk about the
distinction of genre in music
and form in music.
So we're going to go over to
the board over here and you can
see that I've listed the
standard classical genres.
What do we mean by genre in
music?
Well, simply musical type.
So we've got this type called a
symphony and this type of music
called a string quartet and
concerto, and so on.
We could add other types:
ballet, opera,
things such as that.
In the popular realm we've got
genres too.
We've got--classical New
Orleans jazz would be a genre.
Blues would be a genre.
Grunge rock would be another
sort of genre.
A genre presupposes a
particular performing force,
a particular length of pieces
and even dress and mode of
behavior of the auditors--the
listeners.
If we were going to listen to
the genre of a symphony,
we would dress up one
particular way,
go to Woolsey Hall and expect
to be there from eight o'clock
until ten o'clock.
If you were going to hear the
Rolling Stones play at
Toad's--where they do play
occasionally--obviously one
would not come at eight o'clock.
One would come later,
and one would dress in a
particular sort of way and one
would behave,
presumably, in a different sort
of way.
So that's what we mean by
genre, a kind of general type of
music.
Now today we'll start to talk
about form in music,
and what I need to say here is
that each of these genres is
made up of a--
of movements,
and each of the movements is
informed by a particular form.
So with the symphony we have
four movements there:
fast,
slow, then either a minuet or a
scherzo,
and a final,
fast movement,
and each of these movements can
be in one of the number of
different forms and we'll talk
about what they are in just a
moment.
So when we come to the string
quartet, same sort of thing:
fast, slow, minuet,
scherzo, fast.
Any one of those can be in a
particular form.
Concerto, generally,
as mentioned before,
has just three movements and
sonata,
a piano sonata,
something played on a piano,
or a violin sonata with violin
and piano accompaniment--
they generally have just three
movements: fast,
slow, fast.
Okay.
Let's talk about our forms now.
In classical music things go by
very quickly and it's difficult
to kind of get a handle on it,
and we, generally in life,
don't like to be lost.
We like to know where we are,
we like to know what is
happening, and this is what form
allows us to do.
So that if we're hearing a
piece of music and all this
stuff is coming at us we want to
make sense of it by knowing
approximately where we are.
Am I still toward the beginning?
Am I in the middle of this
thing?
Am I getting anywhere near the
end of it?
How should I respond at this
particular point?
Well, if we have in mind what
I've identified here,
we will be referring to as our
six formal types,
and we can think of these as
templates that,
when we're hearing a piece of
music we make an educated
decision about which formal type
is in play.
And then we drop down the model
of this formal type,
or the template of this formal
type,
and we sort of filter our
listening experience through
this template,
or through this model.
So here are our six models:
ternary form,
sonata allegro form,
theme and variations,
rondo, fugue,
and ostinato.
And they developed at various
times in the history of music.
Theme and variations is very
old.
Sonata-allegro is a lot more
recent.
Now of these,
the ones that we'll be working
with today are ternary form and
sonata-allegro form,
and sonata-allegro is the
hardest, the most complex,
the most difficult of all of
these forms.
It's so-called because it
usually shows up in the first
movement of a sonata,
concerto, string quartet,
symphony,
so--and the first movements are
fast so that's why we have
allegro out there,
and it most is associated with
this idea of the sonata.
It didn't necessarily originate
there.
It originated there and in the
symphony,
but for historical reasons we
call this sonata because of its
association with the sonata and
the fact that it goes--
and the fact that it goes
fast--sonata-allegro form.
So that in a symphony,
usually your very first
movement will be in
sonata-allegro form.
Your slow movement,
well, that could be in theme
and variations;
it could be in rondo;
it could be in ternary form.
Your minuet and scherzo is
almost always in ternary form
and your last fast movement
could be in sonata-allegro form.
It could also be in theme and
variations;
could be in rondo;
could be in fugue.
Sometimes it's even in
ostinato form.
So you can see that these forms
can show up and
control--regulate--what happens
inside of each of these
movements.
Okay?
Are there questions about that?
Does that seem straightforward
enough?
We have a big picture of genre
here, movements within genre,
and then forms informing each
of the movements.
Yes.
Student: Did you say
that the ternary form is
normally used for the second
movement?
Prof: No.
I said it's possible that it
is--could be--used for the
second movement.
A ternary form is one of the
forms that could be used with
the slow second movement.
We could also have theme and
variations.
We're going to hear one of
those later in our course.
It could also be a sort of slow
rondo.
So it's just one of really
three possibilities there,
but thanks for that question.
Anything else?
Okay.
If not, let's talk then about
ternary form because ternary
form has much in common with
what we experience in
sonata-allegro form.
Let me take a very
straightforward example of
ternary form.
It's from Beethoven's
"Für Elise,"
the piece--
the piano piece that Beethoven
wrote for one of his paramours
at one time or another.
Here.
I'm going to tell you a story
about this.
My cell phone broke the other
day.
day so I had to buy a new one.
I was really happy about that.
I hated to lose my old Mozart
theme, but I then had to find a
new Mozart theme.
And nowadays my selections are
more limited.
So when you go on to these
things--and in truth,
I actually had my youngest son
do this because I'm hopelessly
incompetent with this kind of
thing--
you go on to these things,
and now they only have one
option for classical music,
one option for--but it's called
"Mozart"
so good choice.
Mozart has become the icon of
classical music and I think it's
the individual that should be
the icon for classical music.
All classical music now has
been reduced down to just
Mozart.
Okay.
I have no idea what that was
about, but, well,
who's calling?
All right.
So we have this piece in
ternary form by Beethoven,
and ternary form is--conveys to
us simply the idea of
presentation,
diversion, re-presentation or
statement,
digression,
restatement--anything like this.
We like to diagram these in
terms of alphabetical letters.
You can think just A, B, A.
>
All right.
I'm going to pause here.
We started out here.
>
We are in this key.
Major or minor?
What do you think?
Minor. All right.
So were coming to the end of
this A section.
Here--The A section is very
short <<plays
piano>>
but then <<plays
we--major or minor?
Major. Right.
>
So what happened there?
What do we call this?
>
It's a very quick modulation.
We've changed keys.
And I'm going to digress here
just for a moment to talk about
this, which is this concept of
relative major and minor.
You may have noticed in
music--and it's discussed
briefly in the textbook--that
there are pairs of keys,
pairs of keys that have
something in common.
The members of the pairs have
the same key signature,
and we could take any key
signature--
three flats or two sharps,
whatever--
but there's going to be one
major key with three flats and
one minor key with three flats.
And I think we have up on the
board here an example of just
that so you can see written in
here the three flats,
and this is a minor scale with
three flats.
Now we could also have three
flats over here,
but we encounter three flats
where we have the major scale.
This happens to work out so
that it's pitched on C.
If we come up three half steps
in the keyboard,
we come up to E-flat so the
relative major--
the major key in this pair--is
always three half steps--
>
one, two, three--three half
steps up above its paired minor.
Here's another one down at the
bottom--happens to have one
sharp in it.
We have the key of G major here
with one sharp but if we come
down three half steps
>
we get its relative minor down
here, and the reason I mentioned
this is not because we actually
hear this very much.
I'm not sure that I hear
modulations to relative major
because I don't have absolute
pitch and I'm not tracking keys
when I listen to pieces--
and my guess is you're not
either.
So for the average listener,
we may not hear the actual
pitch relationship but we may
hear that we've had a modulation
and you can kind of make an
educated guess:
that about fifty percent of the
time if it's going minor to
major,
it's coming in this relative
arrangement--
where major down to minor;
it's going in this relative
arrangement, so this happens a
lot.
So here we are in the mid
section of our ternary form,
A B A.
Here's the B part <<plays
piano>>
and then back to <<plays
the minor A.
>
Now that's just the opening
section of this piece.
It goes on to do other things,
but it's a very succinct
example of ternary form,
and ternary form is a useful
way of introducing a larger
concept,
which is sonata-allegro form.
So let me flip the board here,
and here we go on to this
rather complex diagram.
As I say, it's the most complex
one of all the six forms that
we'll be working with.
It consists of three essential
parts: exposition,
development and recapitulation.
So you could think you were
coming out of ternary form.
You've got an A here,
you've got a B idea here and
then you've got an A return back
here--but this is a lot more
complicated.
There are things--lots of
things--going on.
And I should say also--in terms
of fairness in advertising--that
this is a model.
This is also something of an
abstraction or an ideal.
Not every piece written in
sonata-allegro form conforms to
this diagram in all particulars.
Composers wouldn't want to do
that--they'd have to assert
their independence or
originality in one way or
another--but it's a useful sort
of model.
It tells us what the norm is,
what we can generally expect.
So we've got these three sort
of sine qua non here and
then we've got two optional
parts of this that we'll talk
about as we proceed.
So this is the way we set out
then sonata-allegro form:
exposition, development,
recapitulation.
So we start out with the first
theme, in the tonic key of
course.
It might even have subsets to
it so that we could have one A
and one B and one C up here.
I won't put them up there but
it can happen.
Then we have a transition in
which we have a change of key,
moving to the dominant key.
Transitions tend to be rather
unsettled.
It gives you the sense of
moving somewhere,
going somewhere.
That's why it's called a
transition.
It could also--musicians
like--quickly--like to call it a
"bridge."
It's sort of leading you
somewhere else--and maybe in
that way it is similar to the
type of bridge that Frederick
was talking about earlier.
So we have a transition or
bridge that takes us to a second
theme in--now in the dominant
key.
If, however,
our symphony happened to begin
in a minor key,
then the second theme would
come in in the relative major.
So if we had C minor as
Beethoven does in his Fifth
Symphony-- <<plays
piano>>
So there we are there in C
minor, but the second theme
>
is in the relative major of
E-flat.
Both have three flats in it.
So if you have the start in
minor, then composers
traditionally modulate,
not to the dominant,
but to the relative major--
which is up on the third degree
of the scale.
That's why there's a big three
(III) there.
So then the second theme comes
in.
It's usually contrasting,
lyrical, sweeter.
You heard the difference
there--more song-like in the
Beethoven--
not so much of that musical
punch in the nose as I like to
refer to it,
but a more relaxed sort of
second theme,
and there is oftentimes some
filler or what we might call an
interstice and we come to a
closing theme.
That's abbreviated up here,
just CT, closing theme of the
exposition, closes the
exposition.
Closing themes tend to be
rather simple in which they rock
back and forth between dominant
and tonic so that you could end
on the tonic and that gives you
a sense of conclusion of the
exposition.
Now what happens?
Well, you see these dots up on
the board.
Anybody know what these dots
mean?
I think we--actually we talk
about this if you read ahead in
the textbook Can somebody tell
me what the dots mean*>* Jerry?
Student: Repeat?
Prof: Okay. Repeat. Okay.
So that's what dots in music
do-- when we have these double
bars and dots that means repeat
so we got to repeat the whole
exposition.
If we didn't like it the first
time, we get a second pass at it
in the repeat.
Then we go on to the
development and as the term
"development"
suggests,
we're going to develop the
theme here,
but it is oftentimes more than
that.
It could be something other
than just the development and
the expansion.
It could actually be a
contraction.
Beethoven likes to strip away
things and sort of play with
particular subsets of themes or
play with parts of motives.
Generally speaking,
your development is
characterized by tonal
instability--moves around a lot.
You can't tell what key you're
in--tonal instability--and it
also tends to be,
in terms of texture,
the most polyphonic of any
section in the piece.
There's a lot of counterpoint
usually to be found in the
development section.
Then towards the end of the
development section we want to
get back here to the return and
we want to get back to our first
theme and our tonic key.
So composers oftentimes will
sit on one chord.
What they will sit on will
happen to be the dominant.
So I could put that up here.
We could put a five (V) up here
because we want a long period of
dominant preparation.
>
is where we're going,
back over here.
But we're going to set this up
as preparation in terms of the
dominant that wants to push us
in to the tonic.
So there we are back in the
tonic now and all the first
themes come back as they did
before.
We also have a bridge but this
time it does not modulate.
It stays in the tonic key.
We don't want it to modulate
because we've got to finish in
the tonic here.
So I was thinking just a moment
ago it's kind of the
"bridge to nowhere."
It really is a bridge to
nowhere.
You go right back to where you
were.
You stay in that tonic key and
the second theme material comes
in, your closing theme comes in,
and you could end the
composition here.
Sometimes Mozart as we will see
in our course will end a piece
right at this point--
the end, right there--but more
often than not composers will
throw on a coda.
What's a coda do?
Well, it really says to the
listener that "hey,
the piece is sort of at an end
here."
Codas generally are very static
harmonically.
They're--there's not a lot of
movement.
It's--and I keep--maybe I
should have got-- come up a
different metaphor here--the
idea of throwing an anchor over,
slowing the whole thing down,
simplifying it to say we're at
the end.
So you get a lot of the
>
kind of things in the coda just
to tell the listener it's time
to think about clapping at this
point, or reaching for your
coat.
And the other
optional--Coda--What's that come
from?
The Latin cauda (caudae)
I guess.
Italian coda means tail,
and these can be,
like all tails,
long or short.
Mozart happened to like short
codas.
Beethoven liked longer codas.
And the other optional
component here is the
introduction.
My guess is--Jacob,
what would you guess?
How many--what portion of
classical symphonies--
you're an orchestral
player--what portion of
classical symphonies would begin
with an introduction,
would you say?
Student: Most of them.
Prof: Most of them?
Well, we'll consider that.
Let's go for fifty percent at
the moment.
We'll consider fifty percent at
the moment, so we'll see.
Now let's jump into a classical
composition that begins with a
movement in sonata-allegro form.
We're going to open here with
Mozart's "Eine kleine
Nachtmusik,"
"A Little Night
Music."
This is sort of serenade stuff
that he wrote for Vienna--sort
of night music,
evening music.
Let's listen to a little of it.
We're going to start with the
first theme idea,
and before she does let me play
this.
>
What about that?
Conjunct or disjunct melody?
Students: Disjunct.
Prof: Disjunct,
yeah.
There's a lot of jumping around
>
and that kind of thing.
Notice it's mostly
>
just a major triad with
underneath.
So if we were at a concert and
we wanted to remember this,
we'd probably have a lot of
skippy Xs here.
We don't have time to get into
the particulars of this,
but that's why we're doing all
of this diagramming stuff.
So we got a lot of these
skipping Xs.
All right.
So let's listen to the first
theme of Mozart's "Eine
kleine Nachtmusik."
>
A little syncopation there.
And a sort of a counterpoint to
this, so maybe we've got a
couple of little ideas in here:
A, B and C.
>
Ah, agitation, movement.
Here goes the bass.
>
Pause.
So we had a cadence there,
>.
That would be the end of the
musical phrase,
a cadence, and the music
actually stopped.
I used to like to think of this
in terms of almost a drama.
We've got a change of scene
here the--where some characters
have gone off,
the stage is now clear,
and other characters are going
to come on.
So what characters are going to
come on?
Well, a more lyrical second
theme.
I'm going to play just a bit of
it for you.
>
What about this?
Is this a conjunct melody?
Obviously, it's descending.
Conjunct or disjunct?
>
Very conjunct.
Actually, it's just running
down the scale.
Now we don't have time,
because this music is going by
so fast.
We've got our skippy opening
theme going around like that.
We don't have time to sort of
write down all those Xs so maybe
just--yeah.
>
And maybe something--
something like that.
So this is our first skippy
theme.
Our second theme
>
has a nice sort of fall to it.
Okay. Here's the second theme.
>
Repeat.
Now closing theme already.
>
What's the most noteworthy
aspect of that theme?
>
What do you think?
Thoughts--what would you
remember about that?
How would you graph that?
Yeah.
Student:
>
Prof: Okay.
Yeah.
It starts out <<plays
piano>>
and then it's really conjunct,
right,
because it's staying on one
pitch level,
sort of the ultimate conjunct
joined to the point that it's a
unison pitch,
>.
So I'd remember that just like
this idea.
So our closing theme,
>
almost is the
"woodpecker"
idea.
Sorry.
But think of that kind of
>
or maybe even a machine
gun--whatever sort of silly
analogy you want to construct to
help you remember that.
Okay.
So here we are almost at the
end of the exposition.
Let's listen now to the end of
exposition and then we'll stop.
>
Okay.
So we're going to stop there.
Now on this recording what do
you think?
Well, I think--reasons for
time--let's go ahead and we'll
advance it up to the beginning
of the development section.
So now we should listen to this
whole complex once again,
but we're not going to do that.
We're going to proceed here and
we're going to go in to the
development section.
And it's kind of fun the way
Mozart starts the development
section here.
>
Let me ask you this.
We started here.
>
The development begins higher
or lower?
>
Yeah?
Student: Lower.
Prof: Lower so he's
dropped down to the dominant.
He's now in the dominant
>
and if he continued as he had,
that's what he would have done.
That's not what he does,
however.
>
He's sitting here <<plays
piano>>
and he ends up there
>
so we get this sort of
dissonant shift,
and it's a signal.
It's like the composer holding
up a sign:
"development---time for the
development now!"
Okay?
So something--we've shifted,
we--or a sort of slap in the
face telling us that we're at a
new point in our form,
a new section in our form,
the development section.
So as we listen to this we'll
hear Mozart move quickly through
some--lots of different keys.
I wouldn't be able to tell you
what keys they are.
I really wouldn't.
But I do know that he moves
through different keys.
Then we will hear a
re-transition start,
but here is my challenge to you
and why I'm sort of putting all
these things up here.
Which theme does he choose to
develop here?
Kind of interesting.
Does he go with the first
theme, >
or the >
or the >?
So which one?
>
Prof: Now he is all the
way--first of all,
what's the answer to the
question?
Which theme did he use here?
We're now at the re-transition,
we're almost finished this
short development.
Which one did he use?
Who thinks they know?
Raise your hand.
Elizabeth?
Student: The closing
theme.
Prof: Used just the
closing theme
>
so nothing but the closing
theme in this short development
section.
Now we are at the re-transition
and you're going to hear the
violins come down
>
but if I could sing the
harmony--Maybe we should all
sing it together.
We'll be singing
>.
It's the implied bass line.
>
Then it's going to go
back to the tonic.
Then we're going to go
>.
Then that first theme is going
to come back in here.
So let's listen to Mozart write
a re-transition,
and I'm going to sing the
implied--or then sounded
dominant that's going to lead to
the tonic.
>
So all of the first theme
material coming back--nothing
new.
>
Here goes our bridge
now--movement.
>
And he just cut it short.
The first time he went there
>.
That was what the bass did.
This time he just stops the
thing and stays in the tonic
key.
And then the rest of the
material will come back in in
the proper order in the tonic
key.
All right, but we need not hear
that.
Let's go on now to the coda and
we're just going to listen
generally to what happens in the
coda here--typical coda with
Mozart.
>
Tonic.
It's almost stereotypical.
Right?
>
You could have written that.
I--even I could have written
that--not so hard,
but as they say,
it's just a load of bricks to
bring this thing to a
conclusion.
But it's a beautiful example of
sonata-allegro form.
It does what our model requires
in all particulars in an
unusually rapid rate here--about
six minutes for this particular
movement.
Let's go on to a
rather--another famous example
of sonata-allegro form,
and that's the beginning of
your own Beethoven's Fifth
Symphony,
Symphony number Five.
We, of course,
worked with this before and you
know the beginning,
but let's listen to a bit of
this and we're going to follow
it through now all the way to
the--
into the exposition and
development in terms of form--
not some of the issues we were
working with before,
but in terms of form.
>
So no introduction--just starts
off with his first motive there,
a four-note motive.
>
And now the bridge is going to
start.
>
You get a sense of moving from
point A to point B or from first
theme to second theme.
>
Okay.
So we'll pause it there,
and the horn sort of says
>
"yes, this is the end of
the bridge,"
something like that.
This is the end of that,
and then a new lyrical theme
will come in.
>
What interests--always
interested me here,
sort of like the
"Jaws"
movie.
You never know when it's safe
to go back in the water.
You've got this nice melody of
>
but underneath you have
>.
Sort of lurking under there is
this pernicious four-note
motive.
All right.
So let's listen to the second
theme as it starts in the
violins and then we'll build up
with Beethoven here.
>
Building up dynamics and pitch.
A little bit of interstice
here, <<music
playing>>
our closing theme.
>
A couple of points--note
again--sort of breathe the air
of this particular performance.
Ah. Okay?
It's because we're going to
change to a different recording
now.
Let me comment on the closing
theme.
Notice how in this symphony
Beethoven once again is obsessed
with this four-note motive.
We heard it underneath
>
and at the end how does he
create a closing theme?
>
Well, <<plays
piano>>
just coming down an
arpeggio--just taking that
triad.
>
Is this a major triad or a
minor triad?
>
What is it in relationship to
the opening tonality?
It's the relative major. Okay?
So it just goes from,
>
up to <<plays
piano>>
short, short,
short, long,
so everything's sort of short,
short, short,
long.
All right.
So that's how he constructs the
closing theme--just a different
configuration of that short,
short, short long motive.
Let's go back now and hear a
different recording and tell me
what you think about this
recording.
How does it differ from the
preceding one that we were
listening to?
Let's start with the repeat of
the beginning if you can get
there, repeat of the exposition,
that-- <<music
playing>>
Perfect.
>
Okay. Any thoughts about that?
Just on one playing I know it's
hard.
I should sit the two up here
and play this one four times and
this one four times,
back and forth.
What about this one though?
Yeah.
Student:
>
Prof: The second one
sounds faster,
yeah.
It's the same music.
You--they have the same score.
One conductor thinks this
should go >.
That's how Leonard Bernstein
would do it and did do it.
Another conductor--still
living, conducting frequently in
New York also,
Bernard Haitink
>.
So it gets through this about--
through this exposition--about
thirty seconds faster than
Leonard Bernstein did--just a
difference in interpretation.
So let's listen now quickly,
because it does go quickly,
to Bernard Haitink's
interpretation of the exposition
of this first movement.
>
Prof: <<music
playing>>
Okay.
That's probably enough of that.
Let's go on to the development
now.
Development--well,
how does the development of
this symphony start?
Which theme is he using?
Well, you can imagine.
Prof: <<plays
piano>>
His four-note motive
>
--then rather quickly
he modulates through different
keys.
Every time you hear the strings
sweep <<plays
piano>>
--we're moving to a new key and
then >
modulating to a higher key
there.
Then he begins to build
up--begins to build up in terms
of pitch, <<plays
piano>>
taking it up higher and higher
and higher, and then we get
>
that sort of sound.
Well, first of all,
let's talk about this chord.
What do you think about that
chord?
>
Full of tension, dissonance?
Yeah, it has a lot.
It's called a diminished triad
and we have put this up here.
Remember we've had major
triads, with major third in the
bottom, a minor third on the
top.
And then we had minor triads.
But what would happen if you
constructed a triad with just a
minor third on the bottom and
then another minor third-- two
minor thirds?
Well, you get this sort of more
dissonant sound,
>
a more biting sound.
So that's what Beethoven is
using here, this dissonant
triad.
There is another thing that's
quite interesting and that is
that--
this idea of just pounding away
on one particular chord,
this sound, <<plays
piano>>
that sort of thing.
Beethoven started doing this.
Did you ever have your CD
player get-- <<plays
piano>>
It drives you crazy, right?
Why is he doing this?
So think about how the audience
of that time would have
perceived this.
The--what did the Germans of
1808?
"Ludwig,
Ludwig, was tun Sie hier?
Die ist nicht die Musik.
Sind Sie wacklich? Hier
ist die Musik."
>
--and so on.
So this is a--this kind of
thing-- <<plays
piano>>
It's almost like that kind of
thing they used to use in old
silent movies and then they tied
her up <<plays
piano>>
and then they lit the fuse
>
and then <<plays
piano>>
they're building up tension.
If you take this diminished
triad and keep placing it at
successively higher degrees of
the scale,
you get this extreme of
tension, and what's he done in
terms of note values here?
Well, we have this
*.
It's almost as if he's stripped
it down to just one note--
sort of reduced it to its most
elemental,
and I--well,
I could give you metaphors
about taking matter and reducing
them down to some sort of their
densest potential and atomic
explosions and things like that,
but >
that's kind of what he's done
here.
He hasn't expanded in the
development section.
He's contracted,
sort of to maximize the
rhythmic energy--the almost
electrical energy inherent in
this particular concept.
Well, all right,
so then he backs off of this
>
and gets sweeping <<plays
piano>>
and then he starts playing
around with just two notes.
>
Why two notes?
Well, his original theme
>
had just two notes in it,
and then he breaks it down to
just one note,
once again reaching for the
essence here.
Now this might not sound like
one note, but here's what he's
got.
>
That sounds like high,
low, high, low,
but if you stop and think about
it >
they're just coming down an
octave, so he's really just
working with one note here.
>
And then he changes it
and then the theme
>
but the diminished chord won't
let it in.
>
He just sort of keeps repeating
that one- note idea,
high, low, high,
low, high, low <<plays
piano>>
--"please let me in,"
and finally this sort of
insistent motive <<plays
piano>>
just breaks down the door
>
and then the recapitulation can
begin <<plays
piano>>
--and so on.
The recapitulation begins at
that point.
So that's the development
section of the Fifth Symphony
here,
first movement of the Fifth
Symphony,
where he puts this electrical
moment right in the--
smack in the middle of the
development section--
in the middle of the
movement--and then we get to the
recapitulation.
So we've heard some music of
Leonard Bernstein's
interpretation of this.
We've heard Bernard Haitink's
Now let's go on to--as you go
out, you can use this as kind of
exit music,
a silly--a bit of silliness
here--the Bee Gees'
interpretation of Beethoven's
Fifth Symphony.